if you're like most people chances are
you're using services that live outside
of your cluster for example maybe you're
using the Twilio API to send text
messages or maybe the Google cloud
vision API to do image analysis if you
use the same endpoint in all of your
environments and have no plans to bring
the service into your kubernetes cluster
it's perfectly fine to use the service
endpoint directly in your code however
there are many scenarios where this is
not the case in this episode of
kubernetes best practices let's learn
how to leverage the built-in service
discovery mechanisms inside kubernetes
for services outside the cluster just
like you can for services inside the
cluster
[Music]
one common service that's a good example
of an external service is a database
running outside of your kubernetes
cluster while some cloud native
databases such as Google cloud datastore
or Google cloud spanner use a single end
point for all access most databases have
separate endpoints for different
instances however best practices for
traditional databases like my sequel and
MongoDB usually prescribed that you
connect to the different instances for
different environments so you might have
a big machine for production data and
maybe a little one for the test
environment but each of these will have
a different IP address or domain name
and you don't want to change your code
from environment to environment so
instead of hard-coding these addresses
you can actually use the built-in
kubernetes dns based service discovery
for these external services just like
you can for native kubernetes services
okay so let's say you're running a
MongoDB database on Google compute
engine so hopefully at some point you
can bring a database inside the cluster
but until then you're stuck in this
hybrid world thankfully you can use
static kubernetes services to ease some
of the pain so in this example I created
MongoDB server using Google Cloud
launcher so because it's created in the
same network or VPC as the kubernetes
cluster it can be accessed using the
high-performance internal IP address in
Google Cloud does the default setup so
there's nothing special you need to
configure so now we had the IP address
the first step is to create a service
you may notice that there's no pod
selectors for this service so this will
create a service but it really won't
know where to send the traffic this
allows you to manually create the
endpoints object that will receive
traffic from the service you can see
that the endpoints manually defines the
IP address for the database and it uses
the same name as a service kubernetes
will use all the IP addresses defined in
the endpoints as if they're a regular
kubernetes pods so now you can access
the database with a simple connection
string no need to use IP addresses in
your code at all if the IP address is
changed in the future
you guys update the endpoints with the
new IP
dresses and your applications won't need
to make any changes if you're using a
hosted database from a third party
chances are they give you a URI that you
can connect to if they give you an IP
address you can just use the previous
method so in this example I have two
MongoDB databases hosted on em lab one
of them is my dev database and the other
is production the connection strings for
these databases are as follows now M lab
gives you a dynamic URL and a dynamic
port and so you can see that they're
both different let's use kubernetes to
abstract over this so let's connect to
the dev database you can create an
external named kubernetes service which
will give you a static kubernetes
service that redirects traffic to the
external service this service will do a
simple CM redirect at the kernel level
so this very minimal impact on your
performance and so now you can use a
much more simplified connection string
but because external named uses a cname
redirection it can't do portraying so
this may be okay but services with
static ports but unfortunately it falls
short in this example or the port is
dynamic mm labs free tier gives you a
dynamic port number and you can't change
it this means you need a different
connection string for development and
production anding you to hard code
values for the port which is bad so how
can we get port remapping to work the
first step is to get the IP address from
the URI
if you run nslookup hostname or the ping
command against the URI you can get the
IP address of the database now you have
the IP address if the service gives you
back multiple IP addresses you can
actually use all of them in the
endpoints object the key thing to
remember is that IP addresses behind the
URI can change without notice this
method is kind of risky to use in
production if you are unsure the IP
address won't change with this you can
connect to the remote database without
needing to specify the port kubernetes
service transparently does the port
remapping so mapping external services
to internal ones gives you the
flexibility to bring these services into
the cluster in the future while
minimizing refactor
efforts even if you don't plan on
bringing them in today you never know
what tomorrow brings it also makes it
easier to manage and understand what
external services your organization is
using I'll see you on the next episode
of kubernetes best practices
[Music]